Yo's little pump all right Yo's little
pump catch me on the blue leg cat
broadcast [ __ ]
podcast here one more time broadcast
podcast
what's up everybody's little pump catch
me on the bootleg at Buck podcast
all right
what's up everybody it's Lil pump catch
me on the bootleg cab podcast it's the
podcast
it's the grills it's the grill
all right
what's up everybody it's Lil pump catch
me on the Bullet Cafe
boom
boom boom bootleg cab show special guest
Lil pump Lil pump is here welcome man
good to see you buddy appreciate it man
thank you for having me for people who
don't know the first time I met you bro
was like uh it might have been like two
or three days before your 17th birthday
and you were at uh trapzilla's house in
Pacoima California no it wasn't even
Panorama City California
you and smoked purple just sleeping
there and it was it was just a random
random era of SoundCloud rap yeah that
was when I first came to LA and like I
want to say like that night or the night
after it was like your birthday party
you had your birthday party at like a
strip club yeah yeah
good times man yeah that was like uh
Peak SoundCloud days man literally
what's been going on though
traveling man yeah freaking working
working on a new album okay come out do
you feel like you're focused on music
again yeah I'm back focused on music
there was one point where I was just
like
it's too much right now yeah and you
know I just started [ __ ] off and then
I'm back on my [ __ ] again you're back on
your [ __ ] I was gonna say like
[ __ ] happens so fast for you and you
were like a literal kid yeah and I think
people forget that when they think a
little pump like because when I first
heard of you was um
the [ __ ] J Cole [ __ ] which was like
pretty early would you say yeah I was
like 16. yeah
um but it just happened so fast to a kid
like people I don't think people I think
when they talk about you and they
criticize you whether you know you've
given them reasons to criticize you or
not they forget that like bro you're a
[ __ ] kid and I'm still 22. you're
only 22 years old but you also kind of
like grew up in front of our eyes yeah
no literally you know what I'm saying
like
um do you feel like
now that you've kind of like seen the
highs and lows of this rap [ __ ] like you
you feel like mentally you're in a good
good space yeah I'm in a way better
space now I understand how like [ __ ]
goes and you know yeah I was young I was
just moving fast not thinking about
nothing right
now that I'm older I I see everything
now I was only 16 17 you know I was
crazy man now it's crazy yeah like you
said like I grew up fast it's like let's
say when
this year when I turned 22 people were
like what the [ __ ] pump is 22 I'm like
yeah yeah I'm still a kid you're still a
kid bro yeah it's it's pretty wild uh
talk about um
you first kind of start like I feel like
you became like the the face of
your generation of music for about a
year you were kind of like when we
thought of the sound when I think of the
SoundCloud era of rap I think of you
you're the first first name face that
pops in my head of course the clout era
I think a little pump is that fair yeah
SoundCloud era yeah just that whole I
think you're you're like on the [ __ ]
thing like the mount the Mount Rushmore
of that [ __ ] yeah 100 percent
for good or for bad and I call those
years of rap kind of I kind of call them
the dark years because it kind of I feel
like you're and I still I did stick up
for you a lot because I actually really
liked your records thank you appreciate
it
um like I really [ __ ] with your joints
like I was like yo but the music is hard
as to where some of your counterparts
during that time it was a hundred
percent about
the Antics on the internet
well I feel like you had a lot of stupid
[ __ ] you were doing on the internet
and you were following it up at least
with dope records yeah you know what I
mean of course but then the records kind
of started to fall off a little do you
feel like it was because you were just
lost in the sauce and you weren't as
focused on music you're worried about I
mean you were [ __ ] you were [ __ ]
living life bro for real you was [ __ ]
V-Rod at least I think you're [ __ ]
Veronica Rodriguez one of my favorite
porn stars he was [ __ ] everybody saw
everything but you were like you were
really living that rap rap I mean you
still are obviously you just we'll talk
about why you destroyed the Porsche uh
but
um did you ever feel like you know
during that time like you kind of had to
compete with the last crazy [ __ ] you did
to kind of stay on the top of people's
minds instead of focusing on the music
per se
to me
I I didn't really care what people think
about me because at the end of the day
they're going to criticize they're going
to hate they're going to say whatever
they're going to say right as long as
they keep my name in their mouth
you know that's fair
and
I did everything I wanted to do I moved
my mom out of the hood yeah put my whole
family out of the hood my family
straight
I don't got nothing else to worry about
I'm set that is true man like whatever
people got to say about me they keep
talking but I'm still here how many
strings does this Gucci gang at
it's like it's like damn near seven
times playing it's about to go Diamond
that shit's insane I could have just
dropped Gucci gang and not drop no more
songs and I'm straight for life
and I'm still eating baby not a lot of
people are going seven times platinum
and I'm still torn I just came from
Tokyo Bali Mongolia Slovenia from
Romania I was just everywhere it is how
was it over there that's like that's a
pretty wild part of the world it's
different it's different very different
they loving you over there they love me
yeah yeah they show a lot of love yeah
for sure uh what you obviously you got
the new project coming yes sir this it's
crazy to think that this is um
this is only your third project or is it
third yeah yeah it's your third one
right because you had the first tape
then you had the uh was it Harvard
Dropout and then now this that's crazy
to think man yeah do you like like talk
about the album man like who's on it how
you feeling about it
I'm feeling
very good about it yeah
I've been holding back on it for a
minute I know but it's gonna be it's
worth the way I'm telling you it's
different because
obviously you have the old pump on there
but then I have some new sounds
well you kind of feel I feel like you
started to kind of expand your [ __ ] a
little bit of course the records you did
with X Restless you know restaurants
um that was kind of like a real worldly
record exactly like when those songs
overseas they they go crazy crazy yeah
I'm trying to dip into the Latin Market
a little bit too Latin Market that's
another thing like the latter Market is
way bigger in this market of course like
it's huge are you by are you Bob called
yeah I know I'm saying are you bilingual
yeah there you go I mean you are from
Miami so there's that yeah how's your
relationship with uh with perp right now
good good yeah still my best friend I
love him to death yeah you guys kind of
you had you guys had a run man
with things like was really like y'all
were the two [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying like it's kind of crazy you
know uh take me back bro cause
I feel like uh in retrospect what I
loved about
J Cole right you and him have this sit
down y'all have this conversation which
at the time was so it was crazy to
people unexpected yeah because you had
said [ __ ] J Cole it felt like some of
his album was kind of geared towards
your generation at least if not
specifically to you
um and then you guys have this sit-down
conversation yeah that caught Everybody
by surprise
um how like talk about that convo and
just like did you actually take anything
from it or or do you feel like you're
taking things from it now
after
what do we take from I'm saying like you
know obviously it was a it was an
insightful conversation I feel like J
Cole was trying to give some real game
and like you know trying to understand
the younger generation yeah he was
trying to understand a Young Generation
he because
at that time you know like he people
didn't understand what was going on
right music but they're just like
there's no wave coming in we don't
understand it but
we're just gonna roll with it and he's
trying to understand what was going on
do y'all [ __ ] with J Cole yeah there's I
don't have no problems with him do you
feel like he predicted kind of like what
ended up happening with your rap career
nope because I'm still here I got I'm
not saying that you're I'm not saying
that you're not like still [ __ ] rich
and successful I just mean in terms of
like you know
I feel like
there's so many parts of that
era of rap where like people got famed
so fast they were so young you know what
I'm saying like
and I feel like that was some of the
foresight that he was saying not even
necessarily about quote unquote falling
off you know what I mean
ah you don't think you don't think he
predicted anything
I don't think this [ __ ] no that's fair
I'm still here I mean you're still here
100
hey what up y'all bootleg Kev got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
newest sponsor man shout out to the
homies at hardean Las Vegas that's right
the number one dispensary in the whole
state of Nevada let alone in the whole
[ __ ] country so many choices of
Premium cannabis ladies and gentlemen it
is like how can I put this you walk into
it you go to Jardin in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg Capt sent me they're
gonna take care of you at hardean when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
hardeen is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview
um
you know you got a classic with Kanye
West
exactly one of the uh more iconic
visuals of our of our last five years or
so exactly and most most viewed video in
the first week
is that is that like ever ever you guys
got the big [ __ ] you know the big
shoulder pad joints what do you think
about what's going on with yay right now
hey man I don't have no say-so in that
how did that like initially happen you
guys working together
well
it was this was on my 18th birthday he
had called me
um Six Flags for 18th birthday present
Kanye calls you yeah it was my 18th
birthday I was throwing this huge
mansion party and I just get this random
phone call yeah
and it's yay he's like yo I got some
[ __ ] for you I'm like let's get it I was
shroomed out that day I was shrooming
balls nice
I was out of it and then bro we just
grabbed the studio equipment it wasn't
even though like you know how like a big
Studio big Studio it's not no [ __ ]
Mike no Sony c100 we just grabbed we
literally had a 500 mic wow put in a
small room
lay down the verse send it back to him
that's just crazy and I was like same
night while you're shrooming hard well
I'm shrooming so you record that while
you're [ __ ] shroomed out yeah wow
that's [ __ ] crazy
Schuman balls
was that your what's the your your best
and also worst experience while on
mushrooms because I I dabble in the
shrooms a bit myself I'll tell you what
I I've never had a bad one on mushrooms
but on acid you had a bad Acid Trip yes
what happened I was in a studio it was
me my boy CB were recording for the
Harvard dropout
and I'm taking a piss in a bathroom
and then the whole toilet starts turning
black like in a circle and it just
starts closing I'm like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I put my pants up I start running
in the studio and I piss on myself wow I
was like oh [ __ ] you pull your pants up
while you're pissing I put my pencil
while I'm pissing because the whole
toilet started closing on me like it was
like big black hole just closing I'm
like oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ my pants about
start running I'm like
and I come back to the studio I'm like
book I just pissed on myself
[Laughter]
that was like one of the weirdest
yeah the thing about acid is like really
visual like shrooms can be visual but
they're also like they also like just
have you deep deeply stuck in your
thoughts last time I did it was Sunday
service
the last time you shrooms yeah want to
go see yeah
um Coachella on Sunday service so you
went to Coachella shroomed out well not
on acid oh an acid yeah I was like
[ __ ] eight in the morning wow I was
just [ __ ] tweaking I'm like this was
the last time I do this was that the
only drug you were on
because 8 A.M [ __ ] 8am man that [ __ ]
will keep you up yeah do you feel like
um because you've obviously been pretty
open about I mean you got a [ __ ] song
about being addicted to drugs how's the
drug use these days
I'm not doing drugs anymore what I'm not
sipping drank none of that what was your
Breaking Point with that [ __ ] and by the
way shout out to you for that that's
dope appreciate it yeah I don't know
just I just grew up yeah
when you look back do you feel do you
ever feel like you glorified that [ __ ] a
little too much
not really I mean everybody was doing it
I mean that that plaque mask off the
whole [ __ ] song the whole Hook is
about Molly Percocet you know what I'm
saying exactly everybody goes to their
faces you know that's fair that's how I
feel about like everybody goes to their
face and
now we have a mature low pump exactly is
that what you're telling me yeah
everybody's talking oh I want the old
pump but I'm like you guys want the old
pump like you don't want the old pump
back well also the old pump was on his
way to probably like [ __ ] I don't
know going to jail or dying or something
dying exactly yeah and now with the
whole cancer culture [ __ ] is like
you just got to chill out what you do
because remember like let's say 2017.
yeah there wasn't no cancer culture I
mean it was very light it was like it
was like but it was yeah you the [ __ ]
y'all was posted on like your [ __ ]
Snapchats and [ __ ] was crazy
yeah I was like can't cancer coaches
it's it's pretty wild yeah so many
people are just too soft and on days but
they definitely are I definitely agree
with you I think that it's got the
pendulum swung too far the other way as
to where like before it was like maybe
you could get away with like maybe some
[ __ ] you shouldn't be getting away with
but now it's like yeah it's like nothing
you can't do nothing man you say one
thing oh you're canceled you this you
that I'm like yeah that's why sometimes
it's better to stay quiet and stay out
the way I respect that man you've been
staying quiet and staying out the way
recently
uh now you did do something that is some
old pump [ __ ] you destroyed a Porsche
was it a Porsche yes yeah
I have a history report just man like
well what was the for the video what was
your big music video where you [ __ ] up
a car was that let's get it so the
Escape music video yeah so this is this
is a big story and I never told nobody
this one so
um on the car right the this is not the
plan was not to break the car okay I'm
standing on it performing yeah I cracked
the window
and then I look down I'm like [ __ ] I
just broke the back of a wraith like
and then I just look at the [ __ ]
producer I'm like I'm gonna finish
breaking this [ __ ] like they're already
gonna charge me so might as well might
as well I grabbed the [ __ ] um golf
the golf thing yeah start breaking that
[ __ ]
and then after the video is done
I get a call like a week later like yo
um the owners don't want the car anymore
you got to buy it I'm like what like
this [ __ ] makes no sense right but I end
up buying a car and I got two of the
same whips and one's just [ __ ] up
one's just [ __ ] up and I fixed it
painted it how much did it cost to get
it fixed
they were trying to charge me like
40K I'm like you're gonna charge me 40K
just let me buy the whole car wow yeah
you gotta buy the whip at that point
yeah I was like just give me the car
damn bro that shit's crazy
hey it's crazy too because like when I
said we earlier you're kind of like the
uh Mount Rushmore that Arrow music the
SoundCloud era I feel like like without
you man a lot of people like uh I think
of like a guy like six nine like I don't
think he ever could have existed without
you first does that make sense like I
feel like you kind of paved the way for
like so many artists that got bags
during that time I mean we could go on
and on there was like the dude with the
fake clone uh what was that guy's name
what was the guy who [ __ ] said he was
a clone terrible music
you know you know what I'm talking about
the Clone dude
he was terrible nonetheless you had a
lot of like mini pumps running around
that's for damn sure hey guys we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
good folks over at bluechoo.com that's
right listen you gotta go to Bluetooth
right now sign up for uh Bluetooth with
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
your first month for free Bluetooth the
same active ingredient adds Viagra Ana
Cialis but in a chewable form that's
right you pop the blue shoe chew that
thing wash it down with your beverage of
choice and then get to work with that
hard [ __ ] [ __ ] of yours your dick is
going to be harder than trigonometry was
in high school ladies and gentlemen it's
gonna be [ __ ] Raw like you know uh
Ryu and Street Fighter he'd be like are
you looking and he does the
[ __ ] this is gonna be your dick
it's gonna be like ryu's [ __ ]
uppercut you know what I'm saying God
bless whoever's on the receiving end of
that consensually of course uh they're
gonna thank you for taking the blue shoe
so go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code bootleg all right I'm talking free
month right to your doorstep in discreet
packaging no awkward doctor's visits all
right it's all online you don't have to
worry about going and sitting in a
waiting room and be like hey Doc uh my
dick I could use a little a pep in my
step and then it's awkward you got to
look at this old [ __ ] talking about your
dick he might ask you to pull it out who
[ __ ] knows what's going on at
Bluetooth none of that's happening
boochu.com and they also got the new
brand new a mint flavored chewable which
has vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you whatever
the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll thank you
as long as it's legal all right let's
get back to the interview go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg that's
it
um any features on this album
yes I got um
young boy on the album
I have Ty Dolla Sign on the album okay
I got a few surprises
a young boy [ __ ] had to be
that one's gonna be one of the ones I'm
telling you was that one where you guys
because it feels like he's just kind of
like laid up in the house just recording
verses on [ __ ] day did you guys send
him to beat and he knocked it out or
were y'all in the studio together
just something just sent it over knocked
it out what about what about with Ty Ty
I have something over too yeah any any
but it's but those songs are like like
different it's like a whole nother Vibe
it's not the rapping pump it's like more
of
well the Taiwan is kind of some r b [ __ ]
yeah okay
it's fire
it's purple on the album purpose
definitely on the album yeah
shout out to perp man yeah shout out to
perp man would you guys ever do a joint
[ __ ] uh like another little joint
thing together
yeah you guys coming again
yep
who are you a fan of right now because
you're young I feel like you kind of
I've always kind of been hit to the the
next wave of [ __ ] next wave man I've
been listening a lot of Spanish music
lately
trying to get your Spanish [ __ ] up I
love um this new artist her name is uh
talkiesha she's so hard
I don't know that is so she's super hard
I just saw a Bad Bunny though and that
[ __ ] was crazy yeah Bad Bunny at the
[ __ ] sofa man Bad Bunny that's what
I'm saying the Spanish Market is just so
big you know he did like the [ __ ]
football arena like football two nights
in a row it's insane yeah yeah when you
see that [ __ ] like are you like would
you ever do like a full Spanish album
like some reggaeton [ __ ] I would yeah to
be honest yeah I would yeah
the market is it's insane right now yeah
like it's killing it
um what is for you man now that you're
22 now that you're more mature now you
feel like you're back in your music bag
um what would you say would be like some
advice since you've kind of lived
through it for everybody for up and
coming artists that's maybe 18 19 years
old that's you know
about to really have a moment like what
would be the advice you would give them
maybe the mistakes that to not make that
you kind of had to make for them
I mean just keep working yeah be very
consistent and don't give a [ __ ] with
anybody gotta say like there's no right
or wrong in music right ever like I said
Gucci gang 54 times on a song on seven
times Platinum like you're right or
wrong in that yeah good I don't know
that shit's insane and that that's the
shortest
that's the shortest song that ever top
went on a Billboard charts it was like
well it's kind of crazy because the
whole short song thing I feel like I
could attribute that to you yeah you
started that 100 for that that was all
you that was all me yeah like I feel
like the whole streaming era when people
were like yo we gotta make songs be less
than two minutes yeah or whatever that
was back then were like four verses but
I'm saying like once you came on the
scene and you
skyrocketed the way you did everyone was
like oh this is the new formula because
everyone's attention span's so short
it's so short that's what I'm saying
when I when I started dropping those one
minute two minute songs
that should change the whole game yeah
for sure now look at everybody dropping
no I can definitely tell you like as
from like uh being on the other side of
the industry once you did that everybody
was like everybody started doing that
[ __ ] and or they'd be like yo it's too
long when you'd have like an artist play
your record be like yeah it's got to be
like we're trying to keep everything
under 230 now and that was never a thing
never
that was that was the first charted song
it says like because how long is Gucci
gang
uh like two minutes and something it was
like but like what was boss like a
minute and a half a minute and a half
yeah like that's so wrong
was it was it because like were you
doing that [ __ ] on purpose or was it
just like
I just came on naturally yeah like this
[ __ ] is done and like you said everybody
everybody's attention span nowadays is
way lower so nobody wants to hear a five
minute song like no I mean I feel like
yeah it's kind of crazy you kind of
ahead of your time because now
everybody's on [ __ ] everyone's making
[ __ ] for tick tock and tick tock's what
a minute long you know what I'm saying
yeah
do you feel like you're kind of made for
the tick tock Arrow low key like you you
kind of because you're kind of yeah
I made for anything that's fair uh talk
about uh you've been on some wild tours
man obviously I remember when you first
kind of had like your big tour where you
were headlining
um what is the craziest like backstage
experience at a little pump show that
you remember happening
[Music]
experience
I'll tell you what I remember once I was
overseas
what city was I in I told everybody I'm
gonna throw my ass in the lake it was in
um
you were in Germany throwing yourself in
the lake yeah there was a lake next to
the festival right I told everybody [ __ ]
this [ __ ] everybody come in here with me
won't took all my [ __ ] off had all my
fans literally jump jump it was like
literally like 30 000 people they all
just follow me to the lake was it cold
cold as [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I regret it I
was like oh my god get me out this [ __ ]
right away right away what did I do yeah
but
this show is so insane and another one
was um I'll say wireless Festival in the
UK UK it's insane fire insane yeah
uh are you still only fans no but you
mean I manage girls are only fast how
does that go because there's a lot of
people who do that tiger does that I
think Adam's doing that a lot of there's
good money in that huh
is it is it like when you say you manage
them like what do you bring to the table
you retweet their [ __ ] like you repost
their [ __ ] on your page like we double
their numbers so you're like the
stimulus package if a girl's got an only
fans account and she's not popping she
could sign with you and then you'll
bring the numbers up yes sir excuse how
many uh
girls are you helping
at the moment on the uh on the of
we got a roster get a roster we got a
roster let's say from like 50 to 80.
Jesus Christ you're like [ __ ] Bang
Bros bruh
Jesus you you ever [ __ ] on the only fans
ah
no yes sometimes like I don't even gotta
do that [ __ ] but you've done it before
of course yeah okay fair enough
hey shout out to only fans man it's a
good hustle it's definitely a good
Hustle
Ty I think I know Tiger's got his like a
t raw thing that's booming so
yeah hey we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our
partners at Odd Socks our presenting
sponsor here at the bootleg hit podcast
listen Christmas time is approaching
faster than you think I mean we're like
[ __ ] a month and a half away or some
[ __ ] whatever uh get some Odd Socks for
your folks go to oddsocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world that's
right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy literally the most
comfortable sock in the world I'm
holding the [ __ ] sock right now you
can save 20 off plus they got boxers now
baby all right go to Odd Socks
official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview when you were um
putting this project together was there
any like a
for you like
I'm sure you record a lot so how many
songs got left off the album
a lot
a lot because like how many songs did
you pull from to put the album together
like
I'll say a good 22.
so how many how many how many songs on
Now
22 no
playing
do you feel like uh you have any I think
back to like when you were like [ __ ]
with Diablo and those guys like do you
feel like you got a new producer that
you're like locked in with that like you
guys are you guys got your sound down
and [ __ ] or is it all different
producers I'm locked on to everybody
right now yeah I thought everybody my my
producer right now CB CB mix
CB make shout out to CB yeah
wow any other features
I got a couple Kanye
who knows man who knows who knows who
knows
um it's crazy too because uh
I was just with a fat naked puya and we
were talking about um
kind of like that like Florida
era of music that is so influential to
everything that's going on right now you
know if you think about
Denzel Curry Lil pump smoke perp fat
Nick puya [ __ ]
uh who am I forgetting
um oh they hit the camera
it's all good I'm sorry I'm sorry we
know you could afford to fix it
I'm so sorry
he's got a finger throw a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
got that aim uh obviously Kodak Black
influencing everybody
um
you know do you feel like Florida's
finally because I feel like when you
were coming up people weren't really
like necessarily giving South Florida
their respect their respect and also
like a lot of this [ __ ] was kind of
looked at as underground you know what
I'm saying like do you feel like finally
like Southern Florida's getting it's
like love nationally like of course now
now everybody sees what Florida did yeah
like X2 rest in peace of X he was a big
he was a big influence in it too what
was your guys's relationship like
because that record you guys put out
ended up coming out after he had passed
yeah it was after
we were cool he was a very genuine guy
I've known Excellence I was probably
like 16. yeah that's crazy
but very generous guy fair enough man uh
any song anything else going on with Lil
pump besides the album
[ __ ]
a lot
any movies any any entrepreneurial
[ __ ] going on you're getting your money
like like I obviously got only fans
booming only fans real estate
and I'ma keep buying jury
what's the latest piece of jewelry about
Spike chain from Elliott
how much is something like that hitch
hidden for
250. you spent 250 000 on that mm-hmm
Jesus Christ
you ever regret spending that much money
on [ __ ] after you buy it like you know
when you buy something and then almost
like right away like your stomach hurts
because you're like [ __ ] never
at least you're buying real estate yeah
you're not like totally just [ __ ] off
all your money right nah a real estate
baby how many uh properties do you got
two of them you renting any of them out
are you just living on in them
both both of them are getting rented out
oh can I see the whole other group are
you still in Miami yeah
yeah shout out to Miami there's a wave
going on in there I can't I can't stay
away from the crib I love Miami did you
get any uh this [ __ ] crypto money
going on out there
all the crypto millionaires in Miami
convinci did [ __ ] buy any nfts or any
of that [ __ ]
yeah but that's just done with it it's a
wrap it's a wrap the nft [ __ ] is like
it's a wrap I saw you saw Logan Paul uh
bought uh he bought a [ __ ]
he bought an nft I think for 650 000 and
it's worth ten dollars right now
that shit's insane yeah no but he he for
sure man he's buried off the nfts I'm
sure he did yeah
did you get out in time
or did it crash
I got out of time you got out in time
yeah you've seen it for too long yeah I
was just like what you didn't need too
much [ __ ] what up y'all we gotta stop
the interview real quick tell you about
our good friends at my bookie that's
right man my bookie is where you want to
get this money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview what's
been your uh for you man like you know
who who some of the uh outside of you
mentioned the Spanish earlier but like
what's the music you're listening to on
the hip-hop side nowadays like what's
the last album you [ __ ] with
last album I [ __ ] with
a whole lot of red
really from Cartier that was like two
years ago yeah until the last time huh
yeah I think that [ __ ] though today I
think that [ __ ] is one of the worst
bodies of work I've ever heard in my
life
I still like it when I listen to Playboy
cardi I I in my head I'm like [ __ ] he's
the one artist
like when I listen to your [ __ ] I got it
I was like this shit's hard the Playboy
card is [ __ ] bruh I'm out it's not for
me I like it I'm an old head
whatever it is that [ __ ] they could keep
it I saw him performing at running loud
that [ __ ] was terrible
he sounded like he was [ __ ] seancing
demons on stage it was it was wild bro
to me bro gotta got a good stage
performance like yeah I mean sure like
if you just like someone screaming yeah
I don't know man maybe I'm tripping but
hey shout out to cardi so that's your
last that was like two years ago so
there's been nothing else that's dropped
in the last two years huh
Lucy just dropping tape too it was easy
also on the SoundCloud
Mount Rushmore who else is up there with
you
it's you and Uzi and then fill in the
rest X
who do you think is on there
who else do you put on there
use the X probably
[Music]
I don't know man there was like
trying to think 2017-2018
what do you think Hmm
I'll definitely put Yak up there
Kodak you think SoundCloud
I I see I was living in Tampa when he
started to pop so I kind of saw him from
like a street level like Kodak Kodak is
definitely
I think so the SoundCloud error not
Sinclair but he's on the Mount Rushmore
like oh he's on the Mount Rushmore the
last like [ __ ] five years for sure
yeah that's fair which one's album
driving
I'm dropping on
January January January nice any OG's on
the on the album you had Rick Ross on
the first one
Eric Ross yes
got I got one OG
it's trick Trick Daddy
oh [ __ ] that's fire
everything good over there boys
let's make sure we're good you got your
guys over here like Whispering I'll make
sure we're all right over there
oh okay okay yeah shit's booming if you
had to do a joint album with anybody
right now pump who would it be
you pick anybody
per
I mean that that's easy yeah I just love
making music Widow
there it is man well listen I appreciate
you pulling up appreciate you down
coming on January
January Lil pump two's on the way oh uh
you [ __ ] up cars out here
still [ __ ] up cars doing whatever we
want to do and living life yeah man
listen just don't get back into that
crazy internet antic [ __ ] deliver with
the music and so I'm gonna tell you we
need the records back because you can't
do the Antics without the records not
anymore
there was a time when you could do that
but yeah Lil pump man I appreciate you
bro
boom
there it is